you
you know I've been thinking about as I'm
watching Prince Harry whether he will
keep his beard or shave it for the
wedding and I say that he will keep his
beard for the wedding you do I think
he's gonna shave it want to make a bed
well I have heard that she likes it so
I'm thinking he's going to keep it what
do you say now Noah hundred bucks
favorite charity ladies make it five
hundred to your favorite charity because
it's going to charity
Nora cause it's going to charity yes I
got free children it's on and I'm gonna
win so it's fine I would hate to become
violent I'm a dad did you see if I got
involved in that came to blows on Friday
there's a bridegroom in this story -
welcome Palace released the first images
of Queen Elizabeth's written consent
allows Prince Harry and Meghan Markel to
get married the document signed by the
Queen features symbols of the couple's
background the golden poppies are the
state flower of California that's where
Meghan Markel was born and the three red
seashells on her Princess Diana and her
family CBS News contributor Tina Brown
is the author of the Diana Chronicles
she has covered four royal weddings
since Prince Charles married Princess
Diana in 1981 what are the four they are
Charles and I yeah they are Andrew and
Sarah Ferguson there they are Prince
Charles and Camilla oh and there are
William in Ken William so how does this
one step back up to those I think John
what are you looking for I think it's
the most joyful since the marriage of
Charles and Diana which was an absolute
joy first as you know yeah but this one
has so much sort of modern appeal to it
that I think it has the most relaxed and
fun flavor of any of the royal weddings
that we've seen why do you think that is
because of Harry or because of Megan's
background well first our Prince Harry
really is now the most popular member of
the royal family after the Queen just I
dip sauce Paul just said he is the most
popular after the Queen so he people
adore Harry because he's so
authentic and then Megan breaking so
many barriers down on being the first
biracial divorced royal bride you know
it's it's it's a big thing which has
which has made a lot of the younger
generation in particular very excited
and how much is it the context in which
it takes place I mean there's all of
that you just mentioned but is it or is
everybody hungry for a moment like this
interested me just as when Charles
Mariana which was a very depressed time
after the so-called winter of discontent
and all the bad stuff that had happening
in that end event 70s and beginning of
the 80s this wedding is also appearing
at a time when things a sort of
depressed you know post brexit
everybody's depressed about that you
know nobody much likes the current
president United States and that keeps
on impede you know people don't before a
bad mood actually in the UK right now
and so this this couple represents
everything people can celebrate what
about Megan Merkel's parents and the
role that they will have in the wedding
well I think it's great that Megan has
decided to travel in the royal coach to
the wedding with her mother because
they're very very close and it's a
lovely statement the two of them city
now that's going to be a great
photograph but her father's going to
walk her down the aisle so you know
she's been able to include both her
parents even though they're both they
are divorced and that I think is is is a
lovely way that she has a great way
Megan it seems of being able to figure
out how to include everybody which
except for her half sisters yeah I was
very small on the family side for her
all we're hearing right now it's just
her mom and her dad yeah what I think I
think she has had a fairly isolated sort
of family life it but it shouldn't
really get on great with her half sister
and brother I think was alright early in
the childhood but latterly you know
she's became very successful they were
not and that I think calls something of
a wage so there's a bit of discord there
and I think she made the decision I've
just I can't deal with any of this I'm
just gonna ask my mother and my father
yeah from what we've been told their
parents got divorced when she was 2 and
she really doesn't have a relationship
with those siblings but they just
announced the menu this morning teen and
I thought this was interesting consist
of sweet and savory canapes and bold
dishes that can be eaten while standing
600 people know seated dinner is that no
they there's never a seated dinner
there was one one time diet I had a
seated lunch but the so-called wedding
breakfast cuz British weddings are
always earlier in the day and then there
is this wonderful freestanding kind of
on your feet buffet but interestingly
you know Prince Harry's has said that he
felt that the canapes at his father's
wedding with to camilla were just too
light and to nibbly and too small so
he's actually decreed they're gonna be
very hearty canapes because he said all
his his army friends you'd like to eat
hearty so they can have a big black
canopy would be an example of a hearty
canopy a hearty canopy apparently title
do egg I need tiny Shepherd's pies
they're doing small fish and chips
you know things and a sort of like a
mini hearty menu but tiny bite-size you
know I have to ask you to reflect on
Diana Princess Diana in this moment
you've thought and written about her so
much I think there's a bit it's a
thrilling triumphant moment if you like
for Princess Diana because she was the
big change of change agent in the Royal
Family pre Diana it was so stuffy I was
just talking to the other day - someone
used to fit her clothes of the Royals
and he said you know everything changed
really you know in those latter years
because it used to be that you would put
on a suit and tie and go and fit you
know the Royal remember the royal family
you can turn up now and sneakers
everything's different so it's it's it's
a it's a real change in style but also
you know she she would have loved the
inclusiveness of having who Harriet aged
who's someone he adored that would be
the most important thing and be somebody
who was such a modern confident and
humanitarian yeah
instinct did he go Tina we have to go
but please weigh in Harry's beard or no
beard nor and I have a bet what do you
say I say if Megan likes it it'll stay
if Megan's kind of been saying how do
you shave that beard you know this is
the day that he'll please her and take
it off all right well Steve Thank You
Tina Brown we should note that Tina will
be with us in London for the wedding
itself I'm so excited about so much fun
we'll bring you live coverage of the
marriage this Saturday May 19th our
coverage starts at 4 a.m. Eastern right
here on CBS so Saturday morning please
get up please get up